there's an interesting sort of side
story to the hearing of former Attorney
General Sally Yates and former Director
of National Intelligence James clapper
before the Senate panel yesterday
Senator Ted Cruz like many Republicans
on the panel yesterday tried to
intimidate Sally Yates in a debate about
the constitutionality of Donald Trump's
majority Muslim country immigration ban
but Sally Yates was ready and she
destroyed Ted Cruz on his own turf so
much so that he bailed on the hearing
and ran away Ted Cruz has left after
Sally Yates embarrassed them so Yates
earlier in the hearing explained to
fellow Texan Senator James John Cornyn
that she decided to overrule the office
of legal counsel which agreed with the
Muslim ban because she argued that you
have to have laws based on the truth Ted
Cruz chose not to talk about the Russian
meddling which was sort of the purpose
of the hearing and instead just try to
slam Sally Yates around the Muslim ban
this is so bad Pat that it is almost
painful to watch but let's watch it
anyway Cruz tries to use legalese
against Sally Yates and she throws it
right back in his face are you familiar
with 8 USC Section 1182 not off the top
of my head no well it is the binding
statutory authority for the executive
order that you refuse to implement and
that led to your termination so it
certainly is irrelevant and not a
terribly obscure statute by this express
text of the statute it says quote
whenever the president finds at the
entry of any alien or of any class of
aliens into the United States would be
detrimental to the interests of the
United States he may by Proclamation and
for such period as he shall deem
necessary suspend the entry of all
aliens or any class of aliens as
immigrants or non-immigrants or impose
on the entry of aliens any restrictions
he may deem appropriate would you agree
that that is broad statutory
authorization I would and I am familiar
with that and I'm also familiar with an
additional provision of RNAi that says
no person shall receive preference or be
discriminated against in issuance of a
visa
because of race nationality or place of
birth that I believe was promulgated
after the statute that you just quoted
them that's been part of the discussion
with the courts with respect to the IMA
is whether this more specific statute
Trump's the first one that you just
described my concern was not an ia
concern here it rather was a
constitutional concern whether or not
this the executive order here violated
the Constitution specifically with the
Establishment Clause an equal protection
and due process definitive yes Ted I
know what you're saying here's the law I
looked at which by the way was codified
after what you just quoted a period now
Ted Cruz if he had had an ounce of
common sense at this point he would have
bailed but Cruz tried to stick with it
and says that's exactly what someone who
just disagrees with the politics of the
bill would say and that backfired on him
as well there is no doubt the arguments
you laid out or arguments that we can
expect litigants to bring partisan
litigate critics who disagree with the
policy decision of the president I would
note on January 27th 2017 the Department
of Justice issued an official legal
decision a determination by the office
of legal counsel that the executive
order and I'll quote from the opinion
the proposed order is approved with
respect to form and legality that's a
determination from OLC On January 27th
that it was legal three days later you
determined using your own words that
although LLC had had a legality it had
not addressed whether it was quote wise
or just and I also in that same directed
senator said that I was not convinced it
was lawful I also made the point that
the office of OLC looks surely at the
face of the document and again makes a
determination as to whether there is
some set of circumstances under which
some portion of that AO would be
enforceable would be lawful
they importantly do not look outside the
face of the document and in this
particular instance particularly where
we were talking about a fundamental
issue of religious freedom not the
interpretation
some arcane statute but religious
freedom it was appropriate for us to
look at the intent behind the
president's action in the attempt is
laid out a classic totally out of his
League here and it showed and Sally
AIT's using religious freedom arguments
against a Texas Republican Cruz almost
immediately left the room just seconds
after this ended the a picture of the
empty chair was snapped their cruise
even brought up Hillary Clinton's emails
with James clapper I mean the guy is
just completely out of his League here I
love how this happened because Cruz is
often touted as some great orator
instant debate champion and a guy who'd
wear these ostrich skin boots when he
entered the courtroom right uh he was
out of his league here he even got shut
down by Donald Trump at one of those
debates remember when they were talking
about New York values yeah that's right
and it did not look good for him he's
had a couple of cringe moments over the
last year and a half I almost feel bad
for him except that he's so horrible for
our country that it's hard to feel bad
Sally Yates didn't even have to answer
these questions at all right she just
could have said senator I want to
restrict my answers today to the subject
matter of the hearing not my legal
career or whatever but she dealt with it
and she dealt with it really really well